dans le cadre de mon projet je
m'intéresse aux personnes dit l'actrice
de drogues par injection
[Musique]
mais les différents profils
d'utilisateurs de drogues par injection
bien aussi que certains profils qui sont
caractérisées par bonds des arts et des
récidives d'injection soit pour changer
de mode d'administration de la drogue ou
parce que pour différentes raisons ils
sont forcés à arrêter d'utiliser de la
drogue
on s'intéresse à ces petits teasers et
le voir comment ces flux le risque de
développer différentes maladies par
exemple l'hépatite c con sic cette
population là a de la misère à accéder à
des soins de santé de qualité pour
différentes raisons par exemple ils ont
une crainte des petits team baptisé par
ce qu'ils ont vécu une expérience dans
le passé qui était pas n'étaient pas
extraordinaires ou encore leurs
collègues ont entendu parler d'histoires
d'horreur si on veut qu'ils ont connu
une semaine de bonne volonté d'accéder
aux soins de santé
je pense que la communauté médicale à
travers le temps prêt à abandonner cette
population peut adapter ses soins pour
pouvoir les bien les intégrer bien les
chercher pour leur permettre d'accéder à
sa donc de mieux comprendre si dynamique
là permettrait de mieux intervenir
auprès de la population soit inclinée
que leur offrir les meilleurs soins de
santé des soins plus personnalisé ou
encore de mieux cibler nos stratégies de
santé publique pour pouvoir permettre à
ces gens là d'accéder à des meilleurs
soins pour prévenir les maladies
transmises par le sang par exemple ou
encore d'autres maladies élections qui
sont présentes auprès des populations là
ou encore pour les aider à mieux
intégrer les soins de santé pour traiter
leur maladie du genre l'hépatite c ou
encore le vih